i see this come up time and time again
in the comments
which game is better i prefer this one
or the division sucks they should have
just updated the division one
i'd originally left this because there
are already a ton of videos out there
from quite early on and all tend to be
skewed in one direction
but now in its third year it seems like
a better time to look at it
from my point of view anyway as i keep
getting asked about my thoughts around
this
so i thought why not
[Music]
[Music]
i need to stress before i get into
anything that i enjoy both the division
one and the division two
but for very different reasons having
said that after playing both games
extensively
there is only one that i still
consistently jump into and unless i need
to grab some footage
i tend not to play the other and i don't
see this changing anytime soon
this video breakdown isn't going to be
based on player numbers or any potential
updates in the future
it will be built purely on the current
state of each game today
and another important factor to keep in
mind is that i'll be basing this on what
i look for
and enjoy in a game and i most certainly
don't think that my view will match
everyone else's
for example in this video i'll be
running through the following
and for me these are probably the most
important ones for my experience
it's not that i don't like pvp it's just
that i've never really been a fan of
division pvp
and whenever i have that pvp itch i
usually jump into siege
or destiny but i'll discuss that a bit
later what i'm trying to say is that
it's very subjective to each individual
as to what can make a game enjoyable and
that this is simply my take on the two
games
i put a fair amount of time into the
division 1 recently so i could more
accurately compare the two games
in doing this sort of video i was
particularly concerned about the
movement aspect
as often you'll grow so used to one game
the other one will always feel a bit
off so i put a number of hours into each
game
crossing back and forth between the two
but my initial thoughts stayed the same
i remember when i first tried out the
division 2 the character movement felt a
little heavy in comparison but as you'd
expect
you get used to it pretty quick the idea
behind this change was to allow for a
more realistic feel
the character is carrying a lot of gear
after all fortunately
unlike some other games i can think of
they don't overdo it
going back to the division 1 you do feel
a little more free
for lack of a better word the character
is light on their feet and super
responsive
but overall the movement in general
especially in and out of cover
feels a little clunky in comparison not
game breaking
just not as refined as the sequel
however where the movement went in a
more realistic direction
the weapon handling did the opposite the
division one has considerably more
weapon recoil
and i quite like this it provided a
greater point of difference between the
weapon archetypes
and it gave me more to consider when
playing around with builds
it also meant that attributes like
handling and stability actually mattered
especially on console however this also
provided more of a skill gap
between new players and those who had
learnt over time to compensate for the
recoil
which is why i think they heavily
reduced it for the casual player
weapons being too difficult to handle
becomes a quality of life issue
it also reduced the number of viable
weapons on console for the average
player
and then we have the infamous bullet
sponge issue that a lot of people hated
about the game
this is a luda shooter and a large part
of the game is around collecting loot
and creating builds that work for your
style of play if every enemy could be
killed with a single bullet to the head
the need for builds have effectively
been removed
but stepping back from the division 2
into the original i had completely
forgotten how many more bullets the
enemies needed to be taken down
i can now appreciate the balance that
has been put into the division too
builds still matter but the combat isn't
so sluggish
this alone has made the game feel much
faster paced than division one
probably the biggest letdown people have
with the division two is the atmosphere
and i get it the division one's dark
snowy streets with its tall buildings
looming overhead
really added to the impact of what had
happened in the story it felt lonely
cold deserted and is entirely fitting
for a lawless post-apocalyptic city
and all the hopeful twinkling christmas
lights and decorations
only added to the somber reality of a
christmas that would never occur
then there is the division two while
they did add some of the tall buildings
and dirty streets
with the addition of warlords of new
york it just doesn't have the same
gritty feeling and total immersion of
the original
it's sunny agents are running around in
shorts tank tops
and jandals or flip-flops or thongs
depending on what part of the world
you're from
but if you consider the direction
they've taken with the story it makes
complete sense
in the division one we're operating
around a city only weeks after the
outbreak
discovering what has really happened and
who was responsible
in the division two seven months have
passed we've been through the worst of
the virus
and it's now about helping those who
have survived thus far in
re-establishing order
so to be fair the dark and snowy streets
of new york probably wouldn't have fit
into this change of narrative quite so
well
however with this new storyline that
takes place in washington dc
although not as immersive it's
considerably more detailed than
manhattan
and on top of this there is a lot more
going on this environment just feels
more alive
i'm someone who enjoys open worlds and a
large part of this is because of the
option to explore
to find hidden gems spotted around the
map to watch the npcs go about their
business
the best example of this being ghost
recon although i've enjoyed both games
wildlands just feels more natural and
like there is more going on
it's more realistic and rough whereas
breakpoint
just feels a little dead plus the open
world activities only add to this
rescuing civilians capturing control
points ambushing supply routes
it's made roaming the streets and
activity on its own
the division one had years of balancing
issues with the current meta at the time
and that would change every patch or so
would be the only build worth running
it wasn't just a case of being slightly
better the meta builds would often
outclass everything else in every way it
wasn't until about 1.7 from memory
that the build diversity was in its best
place there were still some meta builds
but they weren't as overpowered as the
previous ones
this was the time of the ninja bike
messenger builds and going back i
actually think i started creating
content around
this time unfortunately this was rather
short-lived
as 1.8 and beyond brought classified
sets to the table
i admit i myself did like the more class
style of play that these gave the game
but i didn't really like how the
classified sets became the only thing to
run
other builds could work but the
classified bonuses were just too
powerful
and so being creative with builds
stopped being a thing
with the introduction of classified
pieces the game also became unrewarding
as the most efficient way of farming
these was through the global events
so in its current form i rate the
division 2 far higher when it comes to
build diversity and post-game
progression
as you make your way through the levels
and eventually get to level 40 you can
start putting together proper
in-game builds immediately where the
division 1 locks you into waiting on
global events
to acquire the best gear
like i said earlier i'm not really a
huge fan of division pvp
previously i used to spend a little bit
of time in the last stand but it was
hardly what i'd call
a competitive experience it was more for
just a bit of fun
as a break from doing other things
however with the division two
it isn't even just a bit of fun it's
just horrible
while the balance of pve is in an okay
place right now the pvp
is pretty much broken unless you're
running one of the two to three relevant
builds in there
you aren't going to be having a good
time to be fair the build variety wasn't
particularly amazing in the division one
either
but at least with game modes like last
stand you could join in in the control
chaos
and have some fun just based on the
number of people alone
incoming unpopular opinion i don't think
the division franchise was ever made
with pvp in mind
of it being one of the main activities
in the game and this idea is only
further supported by what they did with
it in the division two
early on in the game's life cycle i
spent well over a thousand hours roaming
around the division one dark zone
not in a group i was a solo player 95 of
the time
i found it was one of the best places to
farm as you had a greater chance of
finding high-end gear
and set items but there was also always
a risk of having them taken from you by
other agents
the dark zone was one of the first
things that grabbed my attention when
reading about the up-and-coming game
a high-risk high-reward pve vp area
i was more than happy to take the risk
and admittedly it used to scare the crap
out of me when i first started running
it
but over time the developers eventually
conceded to the popular opinion across
the community
and made it so that the dart zone was no
longer the most efficient place to farm
effectively removing the incentive for
going there in the first place
from then on the bulk of the people who
entered the cereal were groups of four
looking for pvp
and of course i keep going in because i
like the challenge of playing as a solo
player
either playing stealth or watching teams
of four coming across me thinking i was
an easy target
however i eventually changed over to pc
and without the reward
i'd just never bother going back and the
division 2 dark zones continued on with
the same issue
except it got even worse at first i
actually liked the idea of the smaller
dark zones
increasing the chance of coming across
other players but it ended up changing
the whole feel of the dark zone
after 20 minutes of running around you
realize how small these new dark zones
really are
completely inappropriate for solo
players stealth was never going to be an
option
and again without any sort of incentive
to go in there they remain fairly unused
this would have to be one of the most
important parts for this genre of game
for these mini mmo style games it's
important to have something to build
towards
well after the campaign has been
completed with the division 1 we have
incursions pvp dark zone underground
survival resistance and legendary
missions
the division 2 has raids pvp dark zone
summit open world activities legendary
missions and seasons
let's take away pvp in the dark zone
because we've already talked about that
underground survival and resistance are
all completely separate dedicated game
modes
the only thing that the division 2 has
that could slightly resemble any of
these
is summit but this fell well short of
the mark
the summit feels like it was a rush game
mode that was quickly put together to
silence some of the complaints that were
happening at the time
and more importantly from a story point
of view we're not even given a reason as
to why we're climbing that building
incursions were intended to be mini
raids or long missions
but it didn't take long before people
were able to speed run these
in the division 2 we got full raids
these were a nice addition that a large
amount of the community still partaking
months after the release but they're not
really my cup of tea
i've run them yes but past the first
couple of times i've found them get a
little boring
i don't buy into the popular opinion of
locking off content from the majority of
the community
i'm a solo player too i don't have a
crew that i run with
i'm not even part of a clan there are
plenty of ways to find groups
and if you don't want to find a group
don't play it you really aren't missing
out on much as far as the raid loot goes
the only other difference that the
division ii has over the division one is
open world activities
and seasons and although these feel
pretty weak the open world dynamic
activities
are still technically in-game seasons
however
i actually liked the addition of these
they certainly added to the reasons to
sign in
but again much like the raids they
should have never replaced other
activities from being added to the game
they should have been in addition to
them
for obvious reasons this would be the
main comparison that's brought to my
attention
i think that the division story is a
fairly typical example of the sequel not
quite having the same impact
as the original examples of this are
anchorman 2
pirates of the caribbean matrix pitch
perfect
from what i've heard the division 1
introduces us to the story
it takes a decent amount of time to
build the scene and set the mood
it was new and exciting where the
division 2 continues the story
it isn't a whole new story it's the
progression we've made from surviving
towards rebuilding i can't think of a
way they could have had the same impact
with the second game
given the way we're moving on from the
initial virus scare
i do however think that the story feels
a little more rushed in the division two
there is a lot going on in washington
and because of this i feel like we
didn't get the same sort of depth that
we had with the more linear storyline of
the original
and this goes all the way down to the
collectibles there were a lot more side
stories going on
missing agents and other recordings that
you could piece together to expand on
the main story
however there is one thing i'd love to
see them continue doing
in the original game we were presented
with the main storyline and that was
pretty much it
we had a few bits and pieces added when
they opened up the west side pair but
nothing substantial
the division ii story has evolved over
time where i think they went wrong
is the way they did it through seasons
after the first manhunt or two
a lot of people were sick of them and
missed out on the future additions
the other thing is that they only did it
through the collectibles the comms
most people would have preferred a
cutscene or two but i like the way
they've continued on with the story
although maybe not told the way everyone
would like it there has been a lot more
happen than in the division one
however i still don't forgive them for
what they did with aaron kina
speaking of which this is another area
that i've noticed people aren't a fan of
the twists and turns the good guys
turning bad
it seems that a lot of people would
prefer straightforward good guys versus
bad guy's story
with the division especially the
division two takes it from more of a
the bad guys aren't completely bad and
the good aren't exactly good
i actually like this it adds a bit more
depth makes it feel
grittier but having said all that if i
had to choose a favorite
it would be the way in which the first
game was told and to be fair
it would always be that way regardless
of how the division two turned out
and however they tell the story in the
future the division one is the thing
that started it all
there is too much history there and over
time the nostalgia
will only grow
from a gameplay point of view the
division 2 is smoother and a little more
fast paced
but when looking at the end game it's
still quite far behind
the sequel has a number of quality of
life additions that made the division 1
feel a little bit of a chore
especially when it came to inventory and
having to restock ammo one at a time
but the main thing that sets them apart
is the pvp
it's like they haven't even bothered
with it in the second game to be fair i
saw the same complaints from the same
people in the first game
but the division 2 certainly didn't help
calm the noise
summing up in my opinion the division 1
is more complete when it comes to game
modes and in-game
but the division 2 is better to play in
almost every other aspect
so tell me where do you stand with the
two games what do you like about each of
them
anyway thanks for watching and i'll
catch in the next one cheers
[Music]
okay